despite his chosen name
alexander's simple castilliev can be a
bit of an enigma
[Music]
nearly got knifed simple of course
trying to push it through
and it's in style
if it goes over time now i'm not is this
gonna happen
if it does happen now that's gonna be
one of the silliest knife attempts ever
like don't
if you're if you're able to close out a
game don't knife anyone please
information that he's that long and in
the open stewie he taps on azus pistol
as well
he's got another pistol the knife does
cost them and liquid take the game in
overtime
double overtime at that but it's that
mysterious and
unpredictable aura that makes the
ukrainian sniper more appealing
and over the years he's amassed legions
of fans with his signature blend of
incredible plays
and his devil may care attitude
but it's not just the reputation he's
crafted in counter-strike
that gets people talking you see simple
as a guy
who hasn't avoided controversy germans
sia in hell germans
he's passionate about some things you
might not expect hey
[Music]
and even more importantly he's the
reason you can put
the hokage in your mouth
believe it believe it so believe it so
today we're taking a look at the facts
about
simple both widely known and less
discussed
because when it comes to the lore of one
of counter-strike's greatest ever
players
the falling off is well just the tip of
the iceberg
see if double smoke is in the same place
there simple just jumping casually into
the side he's going to fall down and get
right there
from simple are you serious what is that
you can't do that simple that's not
allowed this is not fpl
this is a major
[Music]
okay so we're going to talk about some
stuff you might be familiar with
but don't worry things are going to get
pretty weird
pretty fast there's a lot to cover about
everyone's favorite expectation
shatterer so let's jump right on to the
surface of the simple iceberg
graffiti tattoo if you've heard of
simple chances are it's because of his
falling-off play on cash
one of the hypest and quite frankly
unlikeliest highlights
in cs a play so iconic it earned the
ukrainian maestro
his own graffiti on the map but simple
took it a step
further tagging his own body with a
tattoo that recreates the iconic moment
too
his eyes no scope and here's a bullet
you know a lot of people struggle with
deciding what to get tattooed on their
body
but i guess it's easy when you can just
create highlight plays at will
like simple twitch bands
while simple has certainly mellowed out
from earlier days
thank you for game dumas
really nice to play with you you're
playing like
he's been banned several times on
twitch four to be exact
most recently it was for saying a
homophobic slur on stream
although simple argued he was only using
it as part of his attempt
to get a teammate to stop saying the
word and the worst part
during several of these bans there were
accounts pretending to be simple to scam
people
that were still live on twitch there's
someone in my house eating my birthday
cake with my family
and that's not me major problems
oh god it's like a joke holy despite
being widely considered one of the
greatest cs players playing
now and all time simple has yet to win a
valve major
and while he's made grand finals on two
separate occasions with different teams
both of the opponents that trumped him
were era defining rosters
sk gaming and astralis so how important
is winning a major to simple well he's
told his streaming audience that
he has no plans on ending his hunt for
one
would you really quit cs to play all
around listen
if i was australis that won four majors
i would probably think about this you
know
besides i have zero major
i'll keep grinding friction with a leash
even before he joined team liquid in
simple was known for having a bit of a
toxic streak in him
my simple man
so it was no surprise to anyone when
tensions started to form between the
ukrainian superstar
and his new north american teammates and
while the team managed some truly
impressive results
the chemistry between simple and elige
eventually soured to the point where
liquid had to make some tough decisions
which heco talked about with dixerto at
the time
the way that simple's personality was
and the way that alicia's personality
was there's no way that we would have
been able to get both of them there's
just it just would not have happened
there were so many problems we had there
were so many
so many personality clashes and so many
fights that we got into that were just
like stupid fights if you like looking
like from from an outside looking in
in the end it was simple's homesick
return to ukraine that gave him the
clarity of mind
to move on from the roster and
ultimately away from a liege
although the two have seemingly settled
their issues since
and have at least mutual respect for one
another it wasn't really
anything about like having two star
players i think that it was just a very
obvious
personality conflicts within the team
throughout the whole team
to be completely honest so it was very
tough and i think that changes needed to
happen and
we had to do them just straight up okay
so
maybe simple stint in north america
didn't give him the results he hoped for
but at least it gave the cs go community
one of its greatest ever memes
why are you bullying me
for you bully me everyone asking
okay so i think that's enough of the
surface
it's time for us to go a little bit
deeper
friendship with hiko speaking of
relationships that began on team liquid
simple's friendship with hiko is an
enduring reminder that the game is about
more than just results
it can also be about camaraderie since
simple's departure from liquid in 2016
he has routinely pointed to hiko as one
of the best teammates he's ever played
with
hika is my freaking real brother hiko
you're my brother you listen to me you
always was my brother
in bad days and in good days in all
major and old tournaments you're all
liquid
you're my real brother dude the two
first joined forces at a tournament when
heco subbed in
for flipside tactics at eswc 2015
and then bonded during simple's
tumultuous time on liquid
since then the two have kept in contact
and have nothing but good things to say
about each other i see him as kind of
like my younger brother in the scene
and you know if if he ever needs
anything or needs help with anything
like he knows he can message me and
it's vice versa a bit of a showman
now this might not come as too big of a
surprise
but simple's command of the spotlight
extends beyond the server
if you've spent any time at all watching
his stream or pretty much
any content he's been a part of it's
very clear that the man
loves music and singing specifically
[Music]
the cs go community was introduced to
simple the showman when a video surfaced
online in 2015
of him performing a duet with his sister
at what looks like some kind of school
talent show
the song they're singing is called just
a couple of minutes by a pop band named
t9
which was written for a russian movie
called pick up with no rules
everything about this video is a
disaster oh my lord
and although the quality of the cover is
certainly questionable
and it's resulted in simple being memed
upon by his fans
it hasn't discouraged the man from
flexing his vocal cords
at every given opportunity
[Music]
on second thought maybe he should stick
to no scopes
high sensitivity and desk posture
when it comes to mouse sensitivity in cs
many players swear by lower settings
using more of your arm can spare your
wrist some wear and tear
and potentially increase the accuracy of
fine movements
but not all players agree and simple
plays at a sensitivity higher than
many of his peers with an effective dpi
in counter-strike
of over 1200. actually he's a good
position too as well this could be big
majes gets denied did he see the second
he's gonna see utility
he goes back for it he wants more simple
he's got the bloodlust he's up for this
turns it
oh simple it's so good to breathe
whatever the reason he chose a higher
sense
it's clearly working for him but there's
one more thing about his approach that's
a bit different
his posture former cs champion and coach
ron rambo kim did an excellent breakdown
of it on his youtube channel
fps coach another thing i want you to
notice is his
actual mechanical positions so his
aiming arm
you can see that he does have most his
forum on the table
and it's very level or horizontal with
the table it's like
flat right also notice how close his
chest is to the table
and in order to have support a decent
posture with that forearm position
the closer you sit to the table the
better you are for europe back two-year
esl there
this is something you may have heard
rumors of but it
is true that simple was banned for two
years from esl events
the initial one-year ban was for
cheating but
symbol was never caught by vac only by
esl
wire and of course he wasn't caught by
vac i mean does
that catch anybody
in an interview with hltv simple
explained that he was just showing his
friend
how to play with cheats and to
circumvent the suspension
he tried qualifying for esl one katowice
with courage gaming which only earned
him
another year's ban from esl events
fortunately after the ban expired in
simple was able to hit the reset button
on his career
with team liquid in the united states
[Music]
okay so we're about halfway to our
destination
let's plunge even deeper a cunning
linguist
okay so simplest said that when he was
younger he dreamed of
playing soccer like a number of other
noteworthy cs players did
but at the time that he decided to
commit fully to ces
he was actually studying mandarin in
university
to become a chinese translator certainly
a unique
choice of career but i think cs fans are
happy that he preferred
to let his ak do the talking flash off
the door for the repeat
simples
with the ak spray lovely to observe
a bit of a homebody maybe it's not
different from too many of us but
simple as a guy who'd prefer to kick it
at home a lot of the time
or at least be close to his family and
even though he hasn't been on the road
as much
these days back in 2017 simple told pgl
that even when he retires
travel will remain an important aspect
of his life
it's like i don't know i just like to
visit a lot of countries so maybe in
10 15 years i'll stop cs and just visit
or work all right brace yourselves
because now we're heading into
the deepest depths sure are a lot of
fish down here
anyone want some sushi weird apartment
speaking of being a homebody in 2018
simple gave a tour of his place at the
time for the official
navi cs go youtube channel and if you
thought you knew what simple style was
like
you were probably a bit surprised when
you saw the decor
yoda
but whether you like the deep purples
and damask wallpaper in the living room
or not the entire tour kicked up a bit
of a stir
between the bright decor and the bedroom
and the
unique bathroom it was a bit of a trip
but come on guys isn't this a hell of a
lot better than the backdrop we
typically see from pro players
a mostly neutral colored bedroom with
zero decoration
maybe some takeout trash piled in the
edge of the frame
whether or not you agree with his sense
of taste it seems
fitting that simple's apartment would be
like the player himself
one of a kind
sushi business in addition to basically
everyone he plays against simple owns
something else too
a sushi restaurant he and three other
co-owners
one of whom is his brother opened a kiev
sushi restaurant called
ninja sushi it's a bit far for us to
order
takeout but the restaurant's facebook
account has actually run a post
promoting simple's connection
to the business they opened a moscow
location in 2019
as well and while i couldn't find a menu
item
that specifically called out simple they
do
have a role called the hokage almost
certainly a reference to the sniper's
love
of naruto
i watched a lot naruto like i'm
watching whole naruto yeah yeah
all of it yeah
actually maybe kakashi or orbita i mean
it's possible his brother and other
co-owners
also love naruto but it's not hard to
see simple insisting on a reference here
all right guys so a lot of that stuff
was pretty weird
but let's get to the reason that you've
made it this far
it's time for us to descend to the
bottom of the iceberg
he's kind of responsible for the olaf
boost
okay so i figured out a way to get the
olaf boost into this video
so travel back in time with me to
dreamhack winter
2014. simple was part of hellraisers
and they ran into fanatic in the group
stage
thanks in part to a big performance from
simple
it was hell raisers topping group a and
forcing the swedes to the other side of
the bracket
there fnatic immediately ran into ldlc
a team that was fine with playing
overpass
until of course they weren't
all of myself still waiting the patience
game coming i can spot them coming out
of the street door as well he's here
he sees them down there straight
headshot they have no idea
smith's looking confused and dazed and
there's gonna be a follow-up
had fnatic been on the other side of the
bracket the boost
and the now iconic drama that followed
would have been
way less likely overpass wasn't played
although it was set as an unneeded
decider map
in the 2-0 drubbing that simplest team
received from nip
it's certainly possible that without
simple the boost might
not have been used at this event and
both cs go history
and our channel would be forever changed
okay feel free to come up for air now
the deep dive is done
did you get enough weird simple facts
and is there someone that you'd like to
see featured on this show in the future
let me know in the comments below
god damn it there's a fly in this room
kill you come on out everyone asking why
you bully me
[Music]
this might hit my head getting the shot
i can't tell
really
i get the out of here okay sorry i
scared him off
easy
i'm not gonna do explicit t-rex noises
on this show